but can you do this oh wow I bet you
can't
[Music]
we're travelling talking now WA which is
this island south of Japan between
Thailand and and so it should be nice it
should be hot except it's going to rain
damn it
the Queen has been there hooray
we've been in Japan too two weeks now
and we're staying two more weeks for
everyone asking okay there's your answer
we're here it's raining we also couldn't
rent a car because we are not allowed to
drive here product could have guessed
that but we rented cars to another
country before and it's never been an
issue our place is kind of in the middle
of nowhere but it's nice it looks pretty
I think weathers but we decided to go to
the main road I don't know very busy
very touristy anytime we leave Tokyo
it's so easy to get around in Tokyo oh
my god that's a pufferfish but anytime
you leave Tokyo it's immediately so
difficult I can't call it taxi and all
these stuff we're here thank you the
signature move everyone I don't know
what's going on apparently this is like
a famous icecream it's a flavor purple
purple flavor oh my god well pump would
love this ice cream Japan being its
Japan usual we've been seeing these
everywhere here their parent Lee there
to protect your house oh these are cute
hey Marcia
yeah this is underwear now you know this
is underwear I'm tired
where are you going this is underwear
and my said this is me when I get to
monetize you guys recognize these huh
you remember that is aku
wanna get some Evangelion sake that's
pretty cool
[Music]
got that one okay that's kind of creepy
what is the snake drinks
become lucky with money my tea I need
this
big atchoo
go pick it your help I don't care about
you Mario get out of here be my sweets
I'm having here in Japan all right we're
back I'm enjoying some of the sake but I
bought earlier we kind of had a strange
day because we because of the weather
and the fact that we couldn't rent a car
our planes that sort of change but it's
supposed to be beautiful weather
tomorrow so we're hoping for the better
the best there's something I haven't
told you guys yeah okay sure I was gonna
dye it back to my old color this is not
my color this is just the I guess they
try to match the beard mom if you're
watching I should have listened but this
is how I look like now so you guys
better be nice about it okay
good morning today's a lot prettier
outside very nice we're gonna we're
gonna go to a beach now and do what you
do at a beach what do you do at a beach
the water have that tor calls beautiful
smells doesn't it did you fart since we
don't have a car we got to do a 20
minute hike no big deal it's fine we're
heading like to the end over there we
have already discovered the biggest bugs
I have ever seen in my life they were
really big I'm actually scared as well
20 minute hike let's go they're so big
and as soon as you go near then they go
kick and fly in random directions
my sister's running she's like I'm done
I've never seen her run like this
[Music]
and there's a lot of stray cats on this
beach you probably can't hear me because
of the wind let's see how cold the water
is that's pretty nice gum for lunch here
looks interesting this is so cool in
case you're wondering the food was
really good
there's just cats everywhere here
[Music]
oh I see it there that's xxx you see
that they are so big so since we don't
have a car we have to walk through this
minefield what do they call grasshoppers
I could jump out at any moment my
companion hey a lot of people have been
asking why I'm not vlogging
well I mean Japan and the reason why is
because I don't want to draw more
attention to us then we already are we
sort of get recognized way more this
time around couple dozen times a day
sometimes and it's it's fine I think
I've reached this point where I'm like
PewDiePie is so popular I can't tell the
difference if it's a fan or just someone
that thinks I'm famous like if someone
is a fan and watch my videos I'm happy
to take a picture but if if I notice
that it's just someone that wants me as
like in their photo because they think
I'm famous I'm almost like alright
people always like oh you're famous so
you have to just deal with this but
people are so rude as well like it's so
many people are just straight up rude
like taking pictures of us like we can
clearly see you it's so obvious we
caught them then then they'll go like oh
oh sorry can we take a picture and as I
yeah great like you didn't already get
one like usually we get recognized like
and we're used to being recognized but
we also really like Japan because we
don't get recognized all the time and
this time it's been so different that
we're like [ __ ] but yeah
Okinawa here it is the blog we're going
to check out the boat or like you can
see fishes and stuff I know I want
fishes as much as you do I look like
Tintin I can't get over it
it's so bad how did I end up like this
[Music]
that was really fun that was really cool
they were so sweet that family I guess
hey Marcia do you see any reptiles
around here no cuz I see the suck in the
middle of nowhere machine vending
machine hard : Park she could wash away
thank you
that can't be oh my god it's real what
are you doing here he says here on the
road oh I'm sorry
where'd you get back oh no I don't think
good about being me is that mosquitoes
don't bite me cuz I'm like scared happy
have you seen that video where there's a
reptile running away in the beach and
then snakes just come out of the rocks
like 20 snakes they look like this beach
konichiwa if the earth isn't flat then
explain this honestly it's so peaceful
we've been sort of cursing the fact that
we couldn't get a car but honestly just
walking around has been so nice my
favorite part of the trip we're leaving
tomorrow actually you were a quick trip
as always their life over YouTube you
gotta keep making videos
not a youtuber goodbye no everyone they
work ahead of schedule I don't do that
[ __ ] dog this is my favorite sign I've
seen so far myself trim feel like I
needed to proportion my face a little
bang
leave a comment right now what you think
thank you very much for the nice comment
now um we're going back home today so
I'm not gonna vlog but I want to show my
setup in Tokyo and how that looks like
so alright we're back this is how my
setup look at it looks like it's really
just a small bedroom with a room divider
I was so worried that it was gonna be
too loud with neighbors but no one has
complained yet so there we go I got my
origin computer the smaller one which is
so convenient that I could just put it
in my luggage I got this camera while I
was here because mine broke but it works
pretty well got the cushions just to
make the acoustics a little better it's
not perfect but it does the job and I'm
just really glad I can make videos while
travelling so easily I'm so thankful
that I'm able to make videos while I'm
in Tokyo cuz we're really having a
really great time it's so cool - I don't
know it's experience what we always
thought we could do with YouTube because
like I can upload videos from anywhere
technically but now we're actually
putting it to the test and it's so cool
to see that it works so anyway thanks
for watching this vlog leave a like if
you enjoyed and as always here's a
little kissy
[Music]